like people like what do you count as
super intelligence
I mean the these these things are more
intelligent than humans already in many
domains
and and will probably not be as
intelligent as humans in other domains
for a very long time
so what do you count as super
intelligence well let's use sholay's
definition so not being very good at a
specific thing but the ability to
acquire something completely new well
even there you'll have axes of different
regions of tasks where in some places in
context learning is an example of that
right so in context learning works very
well for some things but really not well
for others so what is super intelligence
okay but even on that we're the language
model now people argue that it's
creative but there's post-hoc creativity
and there's input creativity so I give
it a schema a prompt yeah and then so I
might say here's an example of something
generate me 20 variations yeah I would
argue that's